guy you never say this white guy you say
these guys so what
guys do not forget to check out muslim
box call for that
sunnah box set yes you heard it brothers
and sisters each other for your
brother husband cousin dad
granddad uncle great granddad whoever
you want inshallah do not forget to
check them out
you never say this white guy you say
these guys so why when you measure
me listen to me why when you mention a
black guy
you
[Music]
know i'm always out and about on the on
the run so before i do this video you
know why it's very important so
i don't i don't follow football match
yeah so basically i saw a footage um
of him talking to a referee a romanian
referee i think there was a match being
played
in turkey or something like that and
basically what's happened is
that he's going to this person as you
guys saw on the screen and he's saying
why did you say this black guy you know
there's a little white guy you don't say
this white guy
yeah now let's take this from a
different angle yeah you need to
understand when somebody suffers a lot
of racism and we know of denver b
he suffered a lot of racism playing
against some chinese football team i
think in china
where he was called a racist name to
continuously seen this in the pictures
bananas being thrown in
so you need to understand that yes we
could say to ourselves okay if there was
a bunch of black people
and there was one white guy i'm sure the
referee might have said this white guy
uh if he was the only white guy yeah now
we can come from that angle and we can
make it seem
like that in the context of if we was to
assume the best in the referee
that's true we can take the angle but
the point is this problem says when
somebody gets
continuously one after another racism
in and out you need to understand they
become vulnerable in the context of
they don't have the patience to take it
anymore
now can we blame them not really so now
this referee we could say okay maybe he
didn't mean in that context
but to come and say okay this black guy
you could have said denver you could
have known his name or you could say
this guy you could have pointed at him
you didn't have to say this black guy
you know
so i think where he's coming from he's
right in his aspect because he's been
suffering a lot of racism imagine me
like i used to live in a outside london
before i came to islam
um and i used to live in a place where i
always used to be called the word
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was called none of my black
friends would be called [ __ ] and they
were thinking brother
like you should be calling me the like
if you anything you should be calling me
the n-word
they would be called that so the thing
is when you systematically get that i
can remember getting into so many fights
where i used to live
and anyone that looked at me and i used
to get paranoid you know someone looks
at me i'm like what were you looking at
me why are you looking at me
yeah because i would think he's being
racist but that wasn't the case but
because of racism because it
gets you so much you know it's like
imagine you're in an abusive
relationship yeah and you've got your
you know you know this this husband or a
wife continuously violent towards you
next time you get married again and if
someone flinches at you or something you
think are they gonna hit me and they
start bucking out
so i don't really blame him in that in
that aspect but it's very important for
us to understand how
dangerous how dangerous it is to be
racist and we get that i'm so sorry
there are arabs
not all who think they're superior there
are asians who walk around you know with
my daughter's got fair skin who gives a
damn what skin your daughter's got
yeah oh you you make it seem like black
people or darker skin
so this is in our society as muslims we
suffer this
in all shapes or forms yeah and we need
to get rid of this disease
and there's a lot of people who are
hypocritical so that's why it's
important for me
to do this video to raise awareness
brothers and sisters if you yourself you
need to ask yourself this question in
the mirror
am i racist in all angles yes most of
the time i talk about the marriage
aspect of it black brothers
look i'm never gonna go there okay what
i'm saying is are you racist just think
about it
when you go somewhere and you see a
black person serving you etc
what comes to your mind think about that
and i'm just gonna leave
that that's it i don't want to carry any
long brother and sisters iblees
if you want to follow the sunnah of
iblees yeah allah
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
as a sunnah iblis has a sunnah and his
sunnah is raised to them
this is what he said he said i am better
than him
and that is what caused this downfall
because he attributed
a mistake to allah he said you are
telling me to do something
which is wrong i'm better than him how
are you asking me to do something wrong
subhan allah
imagine racism reached a pinnacle for
iblees that he
he said to allah you are wrong and you
made a mistake subhanallah protect us
hope you guys enjoyed this video share
with your friends and family inshallah
and let's
kick put an end to raise them i don't
know if you can point into it but at
least let's do our part inshallah
and stop racism till next time
goodbye sorry i just picked a random
place